Trump just announced
he's gonna ban all transgender women from playing sports
if elected because of one transgender athlete
on the San Jose State University volleyball team
named Blair Fleming.
A interaction from her in a game went viral on conservative Twitter
where they were accusing her of hitting a girl on the other team
in the head with the volleyball.
First of all, that did not happen.
Second of all, if you watch the actual fucking full video,
she spikes the volleyball as one does in volleyball game.
The other girl gets hit in the shoulder,
stands up, smiles,
keeps the ball in play, does not walk off,
is not injured, nothing
is literally completely fine.
Which is why this whole thing is so frustrating and devastating
because Blair Fleming's position on that team,
just her presence on it, has caused four universities this year
to forfeit their games against her
in protest. She has been on the team for two full years
and she also is like not even their MVP or anything.
And now all of a sudden it's like a hot button election issue.
Now teams don't wanna play against her.
And now Trump is using that to fuel his conservative agenda
of trying to get all transgender women out of sports.
Which really if you think about it,
is just misogyny repackage
cause they're acting like they wanna protect women.
But what is protecting women about the fact that now
all the other girls
in The San Jose State team weren't allowed to play their sport
because the other teams are forfeiting also,
what's protecting women about the idea that
if you are a woman playing a sport,
you cannot possibly handle the physical contact
that comes with your sport?
Like, they're saying that that girl who got hit in the shoulder
must be so weak and so feeble
that she could not possibly be
get hit in the shoulder by a volleyball in her sport.
Like, it is so clearly misogyny,
just, like,
blatantly repackaged. And we also know from, like,
Amani Khalifa and other past experiences
that this is going to affect women of color even more.
It's disgusting to me.